CNN's Evan Perez joins us now so Evan this is
getting really really messy what more can you
tell us about these documents found
at the former vice president's home
yeah Victor and Biana this is uh very messy
especially for the vice president and everyone
who's been handling these classified documents uh
the vice president's team was doing these searches
out of an abundance of caution uh in part because
of what they had seen develop in the case of the
President Biden and the documents that have been
discovered not only at the Penn Biden Center but
also at his home and they did these searches last
week they uncovered about a dozen documents which
they then immediately reached out to the National
Archives to alert they found documents that they
thought might be also presidential records act
responsive documents and so that's how this all
got started at about 9 30 PM last Thursday is
when the FBI came to the uh vice president the
former vice president's home in Carmel Indiana
and took possession of these documents about
a dozen documents as you pointed out that
have classification marking things now we
don't know very much about the documents we
don't know what specifically they entail the
level of classification but this is something
that is now becoming a spiraling issue for the
government for the justice department which is
doing a review of this to see what these are who
owns this information which which intelligence
agency owns this information and to see whether
there's been any damage done to National Security
this is part of the standard process that happens
when these documents are found in places that
they're not supposed to be now what we know now
is that you know the addition in addition to these
classified documents the vice president's team the
former vice president's team has turned over four
boxes of documents they arrived here in Washington
just yesterday handed over to the National
Archives again this is just early in the process
we don't know whether the FBI and the justice
department will need to uh to investigate further
whether there are any other places and any
other documents that could be missing Victor
Evan we're going to expand the conversation in
just a moment we want you to be part of it but
first let's go to the White House we know that
we may hear from President Biden on this news
concerning classified documents found at former
president Pence's private home in Indiana the
president is meeting right now with the Democratic
Congressional leaders at the White House let's
bring in CNN's Phil Mattingly so the stories of
mishandling misplacing documents uh have been dug
the president how's the White House Now reacting
to this you know Victor publicly the White House
is not commenting at all making clear that this
is an ongoing matter and they're not going to
weigh in one way or the other privately they are
very cognizant of what's been happening over the
course of the last several hours and I think
when you talk to people inside the White House
they recognize that there is a political element
here in terms of having another example of the
situation that has really kind of consumed the
president the presidency over the course of the
last several weeks one from a republican vice
president in this case uh that shows very clear
parallels and two I think there's a sense that for
Republicans that have been attacking the president
and his actions while he was vice president or
in the wake of his vice presidency on Capitol
Hill now they have to look at one of their own
doing the same exact thing and I think probably
more broadly look white as officials again not
weighing in publicly making very clear that they
don't want a new part of an ongoing matter here
but they recognize the political salience here
and the idea that when you compare two different
vice presidents leaving both of whom have said
that they had no knowledge that these classified
documents were in their possession or had been
transferred to their property those parallels
are important to try and underscore I think a
point that President Biden has been making over
the course of the last couple of weeks now how
this plays out going forward obviously is an
open question but again for a white house that
has been dealing with this in isolation for the
most part trying to draw contrast between their
predecessor former president Donald Trump this
certainly is a an example that very much aligns
with how they've operated up to this point which
once again draws the contrast that they want to
point out very regularly with where the former
president has been on this all right filmmatically
stay with us meantime lawmakers on Capitol Hill
are now reacting to this discovery of classified
documents that Mike Pence's home for more on this
let's bring in CNN's Manu Raju on Capitol Hill so
Manu what has the reaction been thus far well a
lot of members are stunned they really have at
a loss at how this is continually happening and
wanted to get information there's some questions
that will be directed directly to the Director
of National Intelligence Avril Haynes tomorrow
when she appears behind closed doors with
the Senate intelligence committee they have
been asking for questions for ever since it was
revealed last year that Donald Trump had records
at Mar-A-Lago they renewed the requests of Bible
leaders a Republican and Democratic leaders of
that committee when it came to light that Biden
had these documents and now they're renewing
that Crest again in the light of this aftermath
with Mike Pence coming to light and Marco Rubio
one of those leaders of the committee said this
will definitely come up tomorrow behind closed
doors but there's also questions about what else
Congress can do and how these records appeared at
Joe Biden's home even records from the time as a
Senator questions about how that emerged I had a
chance to just ask Senate Majority Leader Chuck
Schumer about specifically what Congress should
do about this in light of these concerns and
in light of the fact that this keeps happening
given that we have learned about Mike Pence having
these documents is it not incumbent on the Senate
to investigate to have some sort of oversight
to ensure that the nation's Secrets aren't being
leaked out everywhere in people's privacy Senator
Peters is looking at bipartisan legislation in
terms of classified documents I support um his
efforts in the meantime on the specific cases
the place the appropriate thing to do is have
special prosecutor and that's what's happening
so Schumer is referring to an effort that was
happening in the homeland security committee led
by Gary Peters the chairman of that committee
to try to change overhaul record-keeping laws
federal record-keeping laws that effort is still
taking shape still coming to light we'll see if
it actually comes to pass but lawmakers really
at the moment trying to figure out exactly what
happened here calls for an investigation on the
Senate side and of course the House Republicans
already investigating what Joe Biden has done
we'll see how they press forward on the Pence
matter as well all right Manu stay with us
we have also Phil and we have uh Evan with
us and let's add Josh school he's a former FBI
executive assistant director for intelligence uh
Josh to you whatever system there is at the White
House or the vice president's residence obviously
is not working well the former vice president
and the president say they didn't know about
these documents their lawyers discovered them
they handed them over Trump's a different story
but is there a simple easy fix so
that this doesn't continue to happen
well Victor I'm not sure there's a simple fix
for this but clearly what's going on across both
administrations is the fact that the policies and
procedures in the White House are not effective uh
it looks like that most of this is happening
during transition and a rush to get out of
the White House I would call on the Director of
National Intelligence to do a review to see what
policies are in place what else needs to be in
place and really do a holistic look and make sure
that this is not continuing to happen so Evan are
we in a scenario now where you have the clintons
and the bushes and perhaps the Cheney's now
scrambling through their private homes to see if
they inadvertently have some classified material
of their own I mean because these things seem to
we keep getting these headlines every few days I
would be shocked if it was just limited to to just
two administrations at this point right exactly
I think that's the big concern you know at this
point we know that you know this happens from time
to time people find documents sometimes uh someone
passes away and a spouse is going through their
their belongings and comes across something that
they no one knew was there and and so this happens
from time to time but you know the the discovery
of these documents or rather the the the legal
fight uh and the the protracted litigation with
between Donald Trump and the National Archives
and the justice department has really kind of
changed the way everyone approaches these things
and this is why you know vice president's Pence
team didn't really take take any action after
the Trump situation because they just thought
that was a complete outlier it's after the this
happened with Joe Biden uh and you know that they
decided to do this search and it does raise some
important questions that I think you guys are are
trying to get at and I think we don't really know
until people you know do these sort churches to
see whether there's anything missing I think
you know it's going to be a working progress
Phil we've heard from uh former president Trump on
his social media about this Mike Pence Discovery
and of course we know the history between these
two uh up to and since January 6th and former
president Trump said Mike Pence is an innocent
man he never did anything knowingly dishonest
in his life I wonder your thoughts on if these
discoveries at Pence's home and who Pence is
and what the country knows about Mike Pence shifts
this conversation from a criminal exclusive to how
do we fix the system and not just you know were
these men trying to use these for some nefarious
purposes you know I think it's important to
separate what the former president has done
when it comes to these documents and his efforts
to Shield some of those documents or not give
them back and where the two vice presidents the
former vice president now the current president
uh Joe Biden have been on these specific issues
however I think when you look at the comparative
if you separate the former president from
this if you look at the parallels between
the current President and Vice President pence
from both of their times transitioning out of
the vice presidency I think what mana's
reporting has been throughout the course
of this day not just in this conversation uh
with Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer but
also with the other lawmakers that he sent in
uh to our operation our his Hill colleagues
have as well it seems or at least has appears at
this initial moment and keep in mind people were
pretty stunned throughout the course of this day
when this news came out that that's the direction
things are headed now to be very clear there is
still a special counsel investigation and there
were still new discoveries of documents in the
president's home just a couple of days ago during
a search by the FBI but I think this is a moment
right now where I think people are grasping the
fact that this is a broader issue one that's
always existed in Washington over the course
certainly in the last couple of decades but when
it comes to this transition process and perhaps
there needs to be legislative fixes perhaps
there needs to be fixes from the intelligence
Community here not necessarily a central Focus or
a an isolated focus on the investigation itself